d'abord je suis extraordinairement
respectueux de toutes religions
[Musique]
je pense que la religion
est ce qu a de plus un portail à une
formule qui les nient catholiques les
protestants que j'aime infiniment ces
deux formules à rabat ce qu'il y a le
plus important c'est dieu
qu'il existe ou qu'il n'existe pas
ça je le crois profondément
donc je crois que plus que toute
politique évidemment que toute
littérature évidemment mais plus même
que l'art probablement ce qui élève
l'homme c'est ce qu'il croit
votre commentaire
je dois faire un commentaire à votre
guise
moi j'ai connu jean d'ormesson un moment
particulier de sa vie donc j'ai pas
connu l'éditorialiste réactionnaires qui
l'a été pendant des années je l' ai
connu à une époque où s'était détaché de
beaucoup de choses et il s'est créé
entre nous un petit liens de sympathie
amusé de sa part 1 et pour être franche
oui j'ai conçu tout de suite une
beaucoup d'affection pour lui je crois
qu'il ya plein de gens comme moi et puis
il avait un talent humour bon mais c'est
la question vous vrai que je parle de
dieu je préfère pas je suis entouré de
gens croyant je comprends qu'elle
fonction joue la foi la foi n'a pas
besoin de raisonnement
c'est une forme de certitude à laquelle
accède les gens par des canaux
affectif et
et penser qu'ils sont très spécifiques
si vous voulez que je me fasse
comprendre plus simplement quand vous
écoutez de la musique dite moi de quoi
parle la musique vous ne savez pas mais
vous avez la certitude que ça parle ça
te dit quelque chose à propos d'une
réalité que seule la musique va exprimer
de la même manière si vous regardez un
tableau abstrait le tableau abstrait
vous parle alors qu'ils ne représentent
rien mais il il vous suggère une
harmonie en jeu des couleurs des formes
et votre cerveau l'interprète dans un
registre
plus d'habitude ils n'utilisent pas les
mots ne sont pas tous les maux sont
beaucoup il n'y a pas de pensée sans les
mots mais il ya d'autres aspects de la
réalité à laquelle on accède par
d'autres fonctions intellectuelles et
mentale ceux qui accèdent à la fois
n'ont pas besoin de nos raisonnements
étant entouré de gens qui croient que
j'aime et que je respecte
je ne serai plus les mauvaises blagues
de ma jeunesse où nous étions assez
grossièrement anticléricaux au point de
d'être offensant pour ceux qui croyaient
non ça je ne le ferai plus et j'ai adoré
tout ce que tout ce que vient de dire
jean d'ormesson pour essayer de se
sortir de l'impasse dans laquelle vous
venez de le faire
est-ce que ça s'apparente un peu ce que
vous venez de dessiner jean luc
mélenchon aux forces de l'esprit évoqué
par wasa mitterrand lors de ses voeux
aux français oui ça m'a pas choqué au
money gram nous croyons aux forces de
l'esprit oui vous savez vous que
j'admets que j'ai eu un côté un peu il
ya toujours un côté un peu
inconditionnel à l'égard de de françois
mitterrand je m'en amuse parce que si
vous voulez dans le monde politique les
gens sont extrêmement frivole il passe
d'une mode à l'autre il brûle ce qu'ils
ont adoré il adore ce qu'ils ont brûlé
donc si vous voulez quand vous tenez
tête sur la mémoire de françois
mitterrand il ya toujours des moments
agréables c'est que parmi une poignée de
lâches qui disait rien tout d'un coup il
y en a un qui dit moi aussi bon bref
alors quand il a parlé des forces de
l'esprit je me suis reconnu dans ce
qu'il disait je suis incapable de vous
dire ce que ça peut bien vouloir dire
mais
je pense comme lui
[Musique]